zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
an diesem freitagabend mehr als 50
deutsche schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler haben heute eine riesen
kontroverse ausgelöst mit dem hashtag
alles dichtmachen offenbar gemeint als
satirische kritik an den corona
maßnahmen
hallo ich bin richy müller ich bin
schauspieler und mache mir sehr große
sorgen um das tor oder virus und
deswegen hat mich immer aus dieser
typenreihe und in diese clique aus wenn
jeder die zeiten atmung benutzen würde
hätten wir schon längst keinen lockt
dort mehr
mein name ist nah die ruhe ich bin
schauspielerin und dank corona habe ich
gelernt zu schweigen danke an alle
medien unseres landes die seit über
einem jahr
unermüdlich verantwortungsvoller mit
klarer haltung dafür sorgen dass der
alarm genau der natur hingehört nämlich
ganz ganz oben und dafür sorgen dass
kein unnötiger kritischer disput uns
bringen kann
von der zustimmung zu den sinnvollen und
immer angemessenen maßnahmen unsere
regierung
ich bin eure gefolgt sind ich bin
schauspielerin ich unterstütze die
korona maßnahmen weil ich das mehr liebe
und weil ich das mehr liebe will ich mir
mehr maßnahmen nur mit mir maßnahmen
komme ich wieder ans meer und deswegen
liebe ich auch die maßnahmen weil ich
dann wieder ans ziel komme schließen sie
ausnahmslos jede menschliche
wirkungsstätte und jeden handelsplatz
nicht nur theater cafés fohlen
fabrik in buchhandlungen klopften nein
auch alle lebensmittelläden wochenmärkte
und vor allem alte supermärkte sind wir
erst am leibe und nicht nur an der seele
verhungert und allesamt pause droht
entziehen wir auch dem virus samt seiner
hinterhältigen mutanten bagage die
lebensgrundlage tja wie das jetzt genau
gemeint ist das weiß man leider nicht so
genau denn keiner derjenigen die
mitgemacht haben wir heute so wirklich
zu sprechen und auch dazu zu bewegen
hier in diese sendung zu kommen um so
froh bin ich dass wir trotzdem darüber
sprechen können mit leuten die das thema
wie geht es der kunstszene und wie ist
die gesellschaftliche debatte gerade die
dieses thema auch betrifft und dir über
die darüber mit uns sprechen können das
sind zum einen julius hartog er ist
gitarrist und songwriter seit zehn
jahren arbeitet er mit andreas bourani
zusammen und sagt diese art von kritik
bringt uns überhaupt nicht weiter
und unsere anderer gesprächspartner
heute abend ist der
kommunikationswissenschaftler professor
christoph neuberger von der fau berlin
schönen guten abend herr professor
neuberger und wir natürlich auch mit
dabei ist sind sie liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer zu hause wir freuen uns
über ihre fragen und kommentare wie
immer in die kommentarspalten der
sozialen medien
oder wenn sie die zdf- heute- app nutzen
bitte an diese e mail adresse und bevor
wir hier miteinander ins gespräch kommen
würde ich ganz gerne schon mal ein paar
kommentare vorlesen
denn wir bekommen hier tatsächlich viele
positive reaktionen auf die clips und
zum beispiel schreibt cornelia gilbert
über youtube das war eine richtig gute
aktion gut gemacht und kreativ sie
sprechen endlich aus was viele denken
wenn satire nicht mehr geht dann können
wir uns gleich einbauen lassen
hartog erste frage an sie was war ihre
reaktion als sie das heute gesehen haben
diese mehr als 50 clips also erstmal
möchte ich sagen also ich habe kein
problem mit satire und ich finde das
natürlich völlig okay wenn die ein guter
schauspieler
dieses video hochladen
so ich will überhaupt keinen diskurs
verbieten aber ich nehme mir halt raus
dass ich halt den standpunkt oder oder
dieser tiere nicht gut fanden und den
standpunkt vertreten wird nicht meiner
ist den würde ich mir nicht zu eigen
machen und das will ich einfach nur
kritisieren und das finde ich ist einer
ist in einer demokratie völlig legitim
dass sich das kritisieren was
kritisieren sie denn konkret weil wir
haben ja eben ein paar clips gesehen
also wenn zum beispiel herr jan josef
liefers sagt dass wir wir hätten keinen
kritischen diskurs und deutschland oder
hat und jemand anders gesagt wenn jemand
der jetzt zum beispiel den lockdown
aktuell den wir dort haben befürwortet
der hätte keine eigene meinung und würde
sich einfach ein paar simons diktat der
regierungen fügen
das halte ich ehrlich gesagt für
schwachsinn ich hinterfrage auch
kritisch die regierung ich hatte mir
eine bessere pandemie politik gewünscht
also die auch eine niedrigzinsstrategie
abzielt wie zum beispiel in finnland
oder norwegen die haben deutlich mehr
gesellschaftliche freiheit im
wirtschaftlich besser durch die pandemie
mit weniger toten und nicht mehr
gesellschaftlicher freiheit bekommen
also ich würde mir schon oder nehmen für
mich schon das recht auf das ist mir
meine eigene meinung bilde und deswegen
finde ich es auch legitim dass sich
dieses video inhaltlich nicht teile und
kritisiere von ihm ein einsatz noch ich
hätte gerne auch mit jemanden zum
beispiel intensiv was heute diskutiert
aber anscheinend wollte ja keiner von
denen heute vor die kamera was ich sehr
bedauere weil ich finde ein diskurs gut
was in der tat interessant ist weil man
ja schon auch gerne ein paar erklärungen
dazu gehabt hätte wie denn bestimmte
sachen so gemeint gewesen waren
herr professor neuberger das sind ja
nicht irgendwelche leute die wir da in
den videos sehen das ist das who is who
der deutschen schauspielszene das ist
meret becker jan josef liefers richy
müller wotan wilke möhring
was glauben sie ist das ziel hinter
dieser aktion was wollen uns diese
menschen damit sagen das ist genau die
frage was eigentlich das ziel dieser
aktion gewesen ich war sehr überrascht
dass das menschen die er doch regelmäßig
im öffentlichen rampenlicht stehen
so will ich glaube ich begriffen haben
wie die sozialen medien funktionieren
die mechanismen der öffentlichkeit
die art wie hier nun kritik geübt wurde
die völlig legitim ist natürlich ist das
völlig in ordnung
anwohner maßnahmen kritik zu üben nur
die art und weise hilft uns glaube ich
nicht sehr viel weiter
das was als ironisch gemeint war ist
doch weil kein gedanke verschwendet
wurde an das leid an die 80.000 toten
doch gleicht so gewesen dass man sie
auch als zynisch interpretieren konnte
es waren relativ pauschale aussagen in
bezug auf politik in bezug auf medien in
bezug auf wissenschaft wo ich jetzt
nicht erkennen konnte wo klare argumente
vorgetragen worden wären die den diskus
weiter bringen und die dinge die jetzt
nachträglich noch gesagt wurden um dinge
zurechtzurücken das noch nicht von der
falschen seite veranlagt werden will
dass man auf die situation der
kunstschaffenden hinweisen wollte macht
hat man das nicht in den videos selbst
gesagt das was sie gerade genannt haben
auch in bezug auf die korona opfer das
schreiben auch einige zuschauer zum
beispiel schreibt radfahrer ohne motor
über youtube ein treuer zuschauer dieser
sendung übrigens der schreibt satire ist
das nicht dass es zynisch muss und der
tanz auf den gräbern der korona opfer
und das spiegelt auch so ein bisschen
das wieder was wir heute an vielen
anderen reaktionen gehört und gesehen
haben folgerte check fasst noch einmal
zusammen was genau in den videos gezeigt
wurde und wie die reaktionen darauf an
von vielen geliebt von mindestens zu
vielen abgelehnt die rhonestadt irische
ab richtung der schauspieler mit der
korona politik der bundesregierung die
video aktion hashtag alles dichtmachen
von tv stars wie jan josef liefers
polarisiert wir sollten einfach nur
allem zustimmen und tun was man uns sagt
nur so kommen wir gut durch die pandemie
werden sie gesund verzweifeln sie ruhig
aber zweifeln sie nicht
und auch kollege richy müller macht sich
öffentlich sorgen
diese clique aus künstler wie igor levit
halten die aktion für falsch sie werde
den opfern der partie nicht gerecht
sachliche kritik ja aber keine pauschale
medienkritik meint er pianist ein auf
gleichgeschaltete medien und hh und das
ist keine kritik das spaltet es führt so
gar nichts ist hilft vor allen dingen
niemandem
die künstler bekommen bei fall aus
gruppen mit denen viele nach eigenen
angaben überhaupt nicht sympathisieren
alois seidl von der afg spendet applaus
hans-georg maßen ex
verfassungsschutzpräsident nennt die
aktion großartig
ulrich matthes ist einer der
international bekanntesten deutschen
schauspieler erhält die aktion für
falsch und sie liefert was ich besonders
fatal finde
schützenhilfe für die gesamte querdenker
szene und die afd die sicher zum teil in
den sozialen netzwerken begeistert
darüber äußern
nachdem shitstorm in den sozialen medien
sind viele schauspieler sprachlos und
geben vorerst keine interviews mehr
einige haben ihre videos zurückgezogen
die aufregung im netz hält an
ich würde gerne das was angesprochen
wurde nämlich den komplex der
meinungsfreiheit mal ein bisschen
vertiefen und da gibt es hier auch
reaktionen es gibt zum beispiel salatics
über youtube menschen die ihre meinung
sagen die nicht den mainstream
entspricht müssen sich öffentlich
entschuldigen und haben angst wo sind
wir nur angekommen diktatur wird immer
offensichtlicher und in das selbe horn
bläst gisela kern auch über youtube
ich sage nur spitze schade nur dass sie
jetzt in den mainstream medien und von
vielen menschen in der luft zerrissen
werden in was für einem land leben wir
zwischenzeitlich es gibt keine
demokratie und meinungsfreiheit mehr
herr hatte wenn sie diese reaktion hören
und sehen was löst das in ihnen aus
unverständnis also es natürlich jedem
steht frei zu solche selbst so zu sagen
aber ich teile sie nicht und ich würde
auch konkrete beispiele nennen warum
also wenn so getan wird als hätten wir
keinen diskurs gehabt wir hatten zum
beispiel über den richtigen umgang was
ist der richtige kurs in jeder talkshow
gab es unterschiedliche wissenschaftlers
gab es wissenschaftliche außenseiter
meinungen wie hendrik strikt der wache
wöchentlichen talkshow hat fast 20
talkshow auftritte dieses jahr das
gleiche gilt während jonas
schmidt-chanasit ja auch eine
außenseiter meinung vertreten hat aber
regelmäßig im tagesthemen und talkshows
also man kann jetzt nicht sagen dass
kritische stimmen nicht gehört wurden
das halte ich für sehr gefährlich und
ich ein punkt ist mir auch noch ganz
wichtig zu sagen ich glaube nicht ja es
waren irgendwie die 53 schauspieler und
schauspielerinnen aber viele haben ja
schon im video zurückgezogen und man
kann nicht sagen dass die für die kultur
und kunst gehen entsprechen also ich
habe heute die mit kollegen telefoniert
aussendung aus dem musikbereich aber
auch aus schauspiel bereich und da haben
viele ihr unverständnis über dieses
video geäußert und deswegen ist es halt
eine meinung von schauspielern aber es
ist nicht die komplette kulturszene
wieso denkt ich würde gern gleich
nochmal darauf eingehen was denn der
kulturszene helfen würde und wenn denn
der gedanke war aufmerksam zu machen
dass es große sorgen in einer branche
gibt die im moment große probleme hat ob
das ziel führend war was diese aktion
gebracht hat das würde ich aber gerne
noch ein bisschen schieben und erstmal
doch bei diesem bei der frage der
meinungsfreiheit bleiben herr professor
neuberger das ist ja harter tobak wenn
jemand sagt wir leben in einer diktatur
und dürfen nicht mehr sagen was wir
denken es gab nur große doku die mein
kollege jochen breyer gemacht hat diese
woche die es auch in der mediathek zu
finden
der ist durch ganz deutschland gereist
und ist diesem gefühl nachgegangen dass
man angeblich nicht mehr sagen kann was
man denkt und was man möchte wenn wir
jetzt diese aktion sehen und die
reaktionen darauf wie sehr spaltet das
die gesellschaft noch weiter ich halte
die annahme für
ja ebenfalls für grundfalsch dass wir
eine eingeschränkte meinungsfreiheit
haben
im gegenteil gerade die aktion zeigt ja
mit hilfe sozialer medien sind wir alle
in der lage ist ohne großen aufwand uns
öffentlich zu wort zu melden
man muss dann sicherlich auch kritik
ertragen wir sollten auch jetzt wenn wir
kritik gegen das auch sachlich machen
damit sich da auch keiner bedroht fühlt
man kann auch nicht sagen dass hier
diese schauspielerinnen und schauspieler
für eine schweigende minderheit
gesprochen haben
wir haben genügend befragungen studien
darüber wie hier die einschätzungen sind
und wir wissen dass diese auffassung
nicht geteilt wird von der von der
mehrheit das ist eine eingeschränkte
meinungsfreiheit gibt dass es eine
kartell gibt ein machtkartell aus medien
und politik das wird nicht geteilt diese
auffassung und das vertrauen in den
medien ist hoch auch in die wissenschaft
ist sogar gestiegen während der
kubakrise darüber gibt das
repräsentative befragungen sondern man
das stützt hier in der tat nur eine
minderheit die eine falsche auffassung
hier vertritt und bei der glaube ich
auch die absicht als solche erkennbar
ist wo offenbar das system gewandelt
werden soll wo institutionen der
demokratie angegriffen werden sollen wie
beispielsweise die medien nun haben sie
gesagt man kann in diesem land sagen was
man möchte aber natürlich muss man
wissen dass man auch den kontext sehen
muss in dem man sich äußert und da hat
man heute erlebt auch bei dieser sache
wieder wie schnell der beifall von
rechts kommt wir können mal gerade
gucken zum beispiel hat alice weidl
getwittert von der afg hut ab vor
schauspieler jan josef liefers genau
jetzt können sie es auch sehen
hut ab vor ihr an josef liefers und all
jenen die sich freiwillig der nun
folgenden hat durch die kritiklose
regierungs fans und leitmedien
ausgesetzt sehen tolle aktion die
hoffentlich zum nachdenken anregt also
man hat nicht nur von frau weiter
sondern auch von herrn maßen zum
beispiel und von vielen aus der
querdenker szene großen applaus bekommen
für diese aktion was wiederum jan josef
liefers dazu bewogen hat und auch das
können wir uns vielleicht auf dem
monitor noch mal angucken sich zu
distanzieren nicht von dem video das er
gepostet hat sondern
von der rechten ecke in die er nicht
gestellt werden möchte in einem langen
schritt den ich jetzt hier nicht
vorlesen kann den kammern aber natürlich
auch twitter nachlesen schreibt er noch
mal ich setze mich kritisch mit den mit
der regierung und den entscheidungen
auseinander aber deshalb bin ich noch
kein reichs bürger
verschwörungstheoretiker corona ignorant
oder alu hut professor neubau wie sehr
überrascht dass das immer wieder leute
auch wie jan josef liefers in diese
falle tappen quasi auch verschwörungs
mythen oder negative zu übernehmen die
die querdenker schon seit monaten in den
straßen verkünden und sich dann am ende
darüber wundern wenn sie in diese rechte
ecke gestellt werden warum passiert das
immer wieder
das ist genau diese naivität ich habe an
die eingangs angesprochenen hat wo ich
auch ein gewisses unverständnis dafür
habe herr liefers hätte ja sehr
differenziert auch in seinem video
argumentieren dass sich distanzieren
können von den von den querdenkern und
einfach einen anderen zungenschlag
einbringen können aber durch diese
verknappung durch das knappe video
doch dann versucht dem auch noch einen
ästhetischen wert zu geben mit ironie zu
arbeiten ist natürlich dann ganz vieles
auf der strecke geblieben und ich sehe
nicht dass wir in der diskussion hier
vorankommen
das ist das was mich eigentlich sehr
enttäuscht darüber von von menschen die
eigentlich permanent in der
öffentlichkeit stehen was hätte denn
geholfen hartog was hätte denn die
gesellschaft sowieso aber jetzt mal
speziell die kulturszene der sie ja auch
angehören weitergebracht ja dazu sage
ich gleich was ich wollte noch einen
eine sache die mich auch an video stört
herr liefers tut so als wären all
diejenigen die so wie ich die zwar jetzt
ein login fordern aber nicht mehr
kritisch denken sondern ich sehe auch
die pandemie politik kritisch aber kommt
zu ganz anderen schlüssen und wie man
der kultur helfen würde es ein relativ
einfach
es gibt gegen kubik 19 prinzip noch eine
strategie die sich bewährt hat und da
gibt es großen konferenz unter ideologen
habe auch ökonomen mittlerweile
virologen und dann ist auch eine
niedrigzinsstrategie zu setzen weil das
virus ist einfach zu gefährlich ist es
hat eine zu hohe qualitäts- warte
und sie können das virus nur bei
niedrigen fallzahlen kontrollieren und
wenn sie jetzt mal einfach so mal in die
welt gruppen also können sie mal hier in
europa gucken also verweise auf finnland
und norwegen
die angriff milde restriktionen aber
hatten nur also schweden hatte zehn mal
so viele tote wie finnland und norwegen
das heißt sie haben erst wieder dass sie
brauchen das vertrauen der leute wenn
sie die pandemie unter kontrolle haben
dann gehen leute auch konzerte wenn sie
ein hohes der hohe incidents farben und
bei einer hohen incidents öffnen so wie
wir das grab haben oder gemacht haben im
märz dann ist es eigentlich die
betriebsanleitung für einen dauerlauf da
und ich hätte mir eine pandemie politik
für ein klar mit einem klaren ziel über
den schritt zum beispiel die new hope it
strategie hätten wie im oktober schnell
gehandelt und nicht erst bei 20.000
fällen am tag sondern deutlich früher
dann hätten wir die zweite welle
deutlich abfedern können es gibt
berechnungen von modell ihre das ist bis
zu 30.000 tote verhindert hatte und das
gleiche sind wir wieder bei der dritten
welle wir fahren handeln viel zu spät
wir locker in die dritte welle und damit
dauert der lotter und immer länger ich
will auch aus dem lok damen raus aber
deswegen finde ich eine intelligente
pandemie pandemie politik so wichtig und
meiner meinung nach handelt die politik
immer zu langsam
nun sind sie einen anhänger der noko
witt oder zero kowitz strategie so zu
sagen haben sie gerade dargelegt gegner
sagen das sind lockdown fetischisten und
genau das ist unser problem die wollen
alle immer alles immer nur zu machen und
genau die leute die ihre strategie
kritisieren sind quasi anhänger von dem
was diese schauspieler heute gemacht
haben nämlich sich quasi aufzuregen über
das was gerade passiert und entweder zu
sagen wir müssen alles aufmachen oder
wir müssen irgendwas anders machen aber
auf jeden fall nicht das was wir gerade
machen
wie kommen wir denn da gemeinsam raus
also ich finde das erstmal vom diskurs
schwierig weil ich meine beine kugel das
hat sich vor ein paar tagen last fällt
also der ehemalige vorsitzende der
wirtschaftsweisen clemens fuest einer
der führenden ökonomen veronika dem
massaker haben sich alle für niedrige
steuern ausgesprochen das sind
spitzenforscher und ich könnte hier noch
zig forscher weltweit aus dem fach
epidemiologie aber auch leute wie armin
hary soziologe viola briesemann etc
haben sich
alle für niedrige fallzahlen aus
gesprochen und ich finde es ehrlich
gesagt diffamieren wenn man den
unterstellt sie seien lockdown fanatiker
damit kommen wir einfach um das kurs
überhaupt nicht weiter ich würde gerne
nochmal darauf eingehen wie die reaktion
heute waren weil sie die kulturszene
gerade angesprochen haben und auch das
was ihr helfen würde und da gab es auch
aus den reihen von schauspieler innen
kollegen heftige kritik auf diese videos
die können wir uns anschauen
hallo mein name ist lutz van der horst
und ich bin der caspar von der heute
show ich möchte heute danke sagen danke
die mutige aktion alles dichtmachen
ich bin vor gestern positiv auf cora
getestet worden
und ich habe keine ahnung wo ich mir das
verfügte virus eingefangen habe danke
dass ihr die leute ermutigt
unvorsichtiger zu sein damit sie in den
gleichen genuss kommen können wie ich
zwei wochen kontaktverbot kopfschmerzen
husten und hoffentlich bald auch hohes
fieber und wenn ich richtig glück habe
dann an dich ja sogar auf der
intensivstation august künstlich beatmet
werden
danke alles nicht machen zeigt jetzt
alle mut scheißt auf das virus alles
ausmachen
jetzt ich möchte gerne zu sagen die
kollegen gerät nur am arbeiten und ihr
seid richtig gut am arbeiten wo es ja
fucking problem alter ja sogar statement
wo in hama und die leute gefallen sind
ja oder statement so menschen menschen
eure hilfe brauchen also und dann kriegt
ja auch wenn ein herr wagner herum frau
turner die lanz erhalten
das spektrum reicht oder vermeiden oder
wie in bahrain postma und dann aufgrund
der ständigen oder eine tolle sandra
hüller statement jetzt gegen einen
shitstorm alter weil ihr scheiße baut
alter da muss man vielleicht noch mal
erklären den namen die ja gerade genannt
hat wagner tschirner im barrique zum
beispiel das waren alles schauspiel
kollegen die sich heute gegen diese
aktion gestellt haben und die kollegen
kritisiert haben für diese videos die
gepostet wurden herr professor neuberger
wenn sie sich das anschauen dann sehen
wir verhärtete fronten einer zeigt mit
dem finger auf den anderen
wenn denn der wunsch und der wille
dahinter war die debatte zu öffnen und
zu verbreitern und den diskurs über die
massnahmen irgendwie in die mitte der
gesellschaft zu holen und sie sehen dass
alles würden sie sagen das ist gelungen
oder das ist gründlich schiefgegangen
ich glaube das ist nicht wirklich
gelungen oder sehen wir jetzt ist es
gibt eine gewisse polarisierung es gibt
jetzt die die kritik für die ähnliche
nun auch reagiert mit mit ähnlichen
mitteln ich sehe da keine versachlichung
ich sehe auch nicht dass das irgendwie
einen punkt gibt der bisher noch nicht
thematisiert worden wäre in der
öffentlichkeit wir haben ja in der
vergangenheit immer wieder gesehen dass
man über soziale medien auch wirklich
sehr sehr wichtige gesellschaftliche
diskurs anstoßen kann dass man auf
probleme in der gesellschaft hinweisen
kann über twitter hashtag aufschrei
feststeckt me to hell städtlifest meter
das waren wichtige anlässe über die dann
die gesamte gesellschaft nachgedacht hat
wo debatten angestoßen wurden
kann ich hier in dem fall nicht sehen
zum einen deshalb weil wir uns schon
über ein jahr mit der frage
auseinandersetzt und der diskurs
mittlerweile sehr viel differenzierter
geführte die frage mich auch welche
medien welche zeitungen diese
schauspielerinnen schauspieler lesen um
mitzubekommen wie über diese frage
nachgedacht wird da fällt das so weit
dahinter dass ich nicht sehe dass das
wirklich produkte umgesetzt werden kann
in den medien ich möchte gerade auf eine
frage oder auf ein statement von rohren
paradies über youtube antworten der
fragt warum nehmt ihr nicht einen
schauspieler dazu der das mitgemacht hat
es ist typisch über die leute zu reden
aber nicht mit ihnen
und dazu sei gesagt dass wir den ganzen
tag und nicht nur wir sondern viele
andere redaktionen auch versucht haben
all diese schauspieler anzufragen und
mit ihnen ins gespräch zu kommen und
genau diese fragen zu besprechen was
denn das ziel dieser aktion war aber sie
haben alle abgeblockt und sind alle
nicht bereit gewesen ins gespräch zu
kommen
herr professor neuberger wundert sie das
ja es ist doch eine sehr schnelle jetzt
reaktionen und auch gewesen man hat es
ja auch in vielen entschuldigen denn
videos gesehen im netz wir hatten ja
auch sie haben auch beispiele genannt
vorhin und wo doch offenbar sehr schnell
jetzt nun auch die einsicht gedämmert
ist dass das keine besonders gute aktion
gewesen ist gleichwohl frage ich mich
das war jetzt nicht nur ein lapsus das
war jetzt nicht nur ein ausrutscher der
vielleicht mal im einzelnen passiert
sondern das ganze müsse eine
konzertierte aktion gewesen sein
moya dann sicherlich auch viele darüber
nachgedacht haben ohne strategie
entwickelt worden ist
umso mehr verwundert es mich dass es zu
dieser aktion gekommen ist ich greife
noch mal zwei meinungen auf die die
aktion gut finden may be schreibt über
youtube ich finde es super aber auch den
eindruck dass bestimmte gruppen ohne
begründung mehr bluten müssen als andere
und kritische stimmen müssen erlaubt
sein ohne dass man als querdenker gilt
oder der rechten szene zugehörig und
ghetto turtle schreibt auch über youtube
die kampagne bringt die schwachstellen
und unverhältnismäßig keiten aller
aktuellen maßnahmen sehr treffend auf
den punkt kunst darf und muss das bitte
mehr davon
herr hartog sie sind zwar kein
schauspieler aber gitarrist und auch
ihre branche ist von den crooner
maßnahmen stark getroffen
die gastronomie ist es auch der
tourismus ist es auch die
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler sind
es auch haben wir heute gesehen aber was
erhoffen sie sich von den nächsten
wochen und monaten dass die kultur
wieder teil unseres lebens wird also
erstmal muss ich sagen natürlich ich bin
als musiker auch enttäuscht man hat
lange die kultur übersehen und hilfen
und sind schlecht bezahlt worden
also dass das dass das teil ich
allerdings glaube ich dass wir die die
pandemie politik der regierung sind wir
jetzt in einer lage dass wir einen
harten lockdown machen in münchen leider
weil die intensiv werden schon wieder
mit über 5.000 menschen beliebt sind
ich hatte mir eine vorausschauende von
der politik mit einem klaren ziel
gewünscht weil damit hätten mit der
kultur geholfen ich habe immer das
gefühl wir sind von einem lok down zum
nächsten haben wir uns durch gehandelt
und ist macht es für uns alle so so
anstrengen
ok und der blick in die zukunft die ja
vielleicht nicht ganz so anstrengend
hoffentlich ist hoffen sie dass in den
nächsten tagen und wochen eine öffnung
möglich ist und haben sich vielleicht
auch deshalb über den zeitpunkt
gewundert wenn man sieht dass langsam
das impfen irgendwie ins rollen kommt
wenn man hoffen kann dass wenn die
dritte welle dennoch mal vorbei ist die
zahlen wieder runtergehen und der sommer
kommt dass man dann vielleicht
möglichkeiten hat in österreich zum
beispiel wird das ja jetzt schon wieder
geplant wie sehr wie schnell hoffen sie
dass da wieder was geht und noch mal wie
sehr wundert sie dieser zeitpunkt
ausgerechnet jetzt mit diesem mit dieser
video aktion der zeitpunkt wundert mich
sehr weil ich meine wir wissen doch
eigentlich alle also die kranken pfleger
und pflegerinnen und die ärztin die
stationen die sind mit ihren kräften am
ende und ich finde dass an einem
zeitpunkt wo noch mal die haben die
menschen aktuell in unserem live station
bin nicht den zeitpunkt einfach
unglücklich
ich glaube halt
wir müssen schnell diensten wir müssen
die fallzahlen rücken weil hohe
fallzahlen begünstigen migration und und
das wäre jetzt das blödeste was uns
passieren können
wir müssen uns noch ein bisschen
gedulden es gibt genug grund
optimistisch zu sein perspektive aber
wir müssen halt wochen noch ein bisschen
durchhalten und dann wird auch
perspektivisch die lage besser auch für
die kultur weil sie die pfleger schon
pflegerinnen und pfleger schon öfter
angesprochen haben möchte ich darauf
gerne noch mal ein bisschen vertiefter
eingehen
ingo kessler schreibt über facebook ich
habe mich echt fremd geschämt als ich
die videos gesehen habe und war von
manch einem sehr enttäuscht dass
verhöhnt die opfer und das
pflegepersonal die maßnahmen der
regierung kann man in frage stellen aber
eine pandemie mit schwer kranken und
toten ist nichts für ironie
dazu passt auch ein tweet von tobias
schlegl den wir uns auch gerade noch mal
angucken können hier über den
monitor vielen bekannt als autor
moderator und aber eben auch als
notfallsanitäter und er hat als antwort
geschrieben die schauspieler innen von
alles dichtmachen können sich ihre
ironie gerne mal tief ins beatmungsgerät
schieben also dass es einer der weiß wie
es auf den intensivstationen ist und wie
die situation dort ist herr professor
neuberger vor einem jahr ungefähr haben
wir alle noch geklatscht und haben die
pflegekräfte unterstützt symbolisch und
haben versucht hinter ihnen zustehen und
jetzt ein jahr später sehen wir das was
da passiert ja dass offenbar eine fatale
normalisierung eingetreten dass man
einfach davon ausgeht dass die
pflegekräfte vollen einsatz bringen bis
an die hand ihre kräfte gehen
vor einem jahr hat man das noch
registriert weil es neu war dass man
gemerkt hat dass da leute an die
belastungsgrenze gehen
aber wie man das so oft hat in den
medien das tritt dann einfach eine
normalität an man nimmt das als
selbstverständlich hin
insofern ist es wichtig wenn man
aktionen startet auch das dann zu
würdigen nicht nur das land sondern auch
diejenigen die sich für die für die
kranken einsetzen
ich möchte gerne noch jan josef liefers
zitieren von dem ich gerade lese dass er
sich inzwischen geäußert hat und zwar im
wdr
das scheint ein sehr witziges interview
gewesen zu sein was wir jetzt hier nicht
zeigen können da mal was man sich ja
dann natürlich anschauen kann aber da
hat er unter anderem wohl zu der frage
welche klischees er da wohl wissentlich
bedient hat geantwortet wir haben nichts
bedient wir haben einfach unsere sache
gemacht die wir machen wollten und
nichts bedient es hat er uns her keiner
aufgefordert könnt ihr uns bitte
bedienen herr professor neuberger wenn
ich das lese noch mal die frage sie
haben gesagt das sind sehr sehr weise
kluge intelligente schauspieler und
menschen die das machen
noch mal die frage natürlich
unterstellen wären liefers nicht dass er
irgendwas und jemanden bedienen wollte
aber trotzdem nochmal sich zu wundern
was das auslöst wie glaubwürdig ist das
ja ist es in der tat so offenbar haben
sie sich darauf ein abruptes feld gewagt
mit mit mit diesen mit diesem video was
wo sie geglaubt haben sie müssen kurz
garantiert
ironisch irgendwie unterhalts haben
wobei ich das selbst dafür bis mäßig es
enthalte was ich da gesehen habe aber
damit eben auch mit einer enormen
pauschalisierung ich hatte gerade in dem
video von jan loos des briefes vieles
daran erinnert was wir vor ungefähr fünf
jahren in anlehung lügen presse kritik
gehört haben von peta so verkürzt war
das einfach wenn er das differenziert
machen will
das scheint darum scheint er sich jetzt
stärker zu bemühen
dann bitte aber dann ist das auch nicht
das geeignete format dann hat er
offenbar auch gesagt ich möchte gerne
dass diese regierungsentscheidungen
transparenter sind und nicht einfach so
stattfinden hinter verschlossenen türen
und ministerpräsidenten runden was jetzt
auch eine gewisse ironie in sich birgt
weil gerade diese woche das
infektionsschutzgesetz beschlossen wurde
und alles in den bundestag verlagert
wurde und eben raus aus diesem runden
was viele ja auch schon als erfolg für
transparenz gesehen haben wir haben
heute gelesen dass gesundheitsminister
jens spahn reagiert hat und sagt er ist
dialog bereit
er kann sich gut vorstellen mit den
initiatoren von alles dichtmachen zu
sprechen und sagt dass es kritik und
fragen an den maßnahmen und den
hintergründen gibt das finde ich nicht
normal
das finde ich in einer freiheitlichen
demokratie wünschenswert
herr professor neuberger was würden sie
denn sagen wie kann man konstruktiv
versöhnlich enden wenn man sagt das hat
nicht so ganz funktioniert wie es hätte
funktionieren sollen was daraus können
wir denn für eine gesellschaftliche
debatte nutzen
in der wir vorankommen miteinander
wir müssen miteinander reden wir müssen
uns treffen und zwar beide seiten und
zwar unter bedingungen wo in wirklicher
diskurs möglich ist also ich könnte mir
sehr gut vorstellen dass das zdf nun
einige dieser schauspieler und
schauspieler einlädt die auch dann mit
mit leuten konfrontiert ja auch eine
andere auffassung einnehmen dann wenn
man dann guten gepflegten diskurs führen
kann glaube ich sind wir sehr viel
weiter als das was wir heute erlebt
haben er hat es ist ihre perspektive
dem kann ich nicht wo anschließend was
herr neubauer neuberger sagt weil ich
dich genauso also ich finde dialogbereit
ich würde auch jederzeit mit herrn
liefers reden und gebracht ist wichtig
und dann kann man das nämlich gar nicht
einfach aus das diktieren
in diesem sinne sage ich ganz herzlichen
dank an die beiden gesprächspartner
heute abend julius hartog und christoph
neuberger ich danke ihnen fürs
mitdiskutieren zu hause und fürs
zuschauen und wünsche ihnen ein schönes
wochenende und bleiben sie miteinander
im gespräch